my mom dukes gave me this ring right
here like I'll take everything else off
but I'll never take this one cardi B
honors takeoff with a touching tribute
days after his tragic death you know you
get to share
life-changing moments with people who
you change your life for cardi whose
husband offset is the late rapper's
cousin and fellow Migos member retweeted
a video from complex music where takeoff
shares the best gift he's received from
offset and his uncle and bandmate quavo
my dude's name in this ring right here I
mean when I'm saying it's a picture of
man that's fire and it don't matter if I
have every ring on my finger Iced Out
somebody will say something about this
ring right here yeah so it always said I
was gonna stay with me too I mean like I
don't never take it off I gotta take
everything else but I'll never take this
one offset who's yet to speak out since
takeoff's death also honored his cousin
on social media changing his profile
photo on Instagram to one of takeoff you
are affecting culture across pop music
everywhere who doesn't understand who
needs to know you know the whole world
need to know if you you know what I'm
saying if you're part of the culture and
a part of hip-hop and music you need to
know takeoff died early Tuesday morning
after a fatal shooting in Houston I mean
it's it's it's it's it's devastating he
was
my abiding memory of him
was it just was so kind he was so laid
back he was funny James Corden recently
opened up to E.T about the time he spent
with takeoff the late musician appeared
on The Late Late Show several times
including carpool karaoke
[Music]
he'd always call me big trip if I saw
him which he knew I just loved and it's
like look what what he did
like his imprint on on what he did you
know obviously you know with his band
like I never knew until I heard the news
of his passing that the reason he was
called takeoff was because often he
would just record all his verses in one
take and that was it he was such an
accomplished musician what he did like
he changed the needle on trap music it's
devastating and um well like we've
really lost someone incredibly
incredibly special there we really
really have